[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen war zu uns hier
in unserer kleinen süss micro welt und
meine lieben freunde wir dürfen gar
nicht lange zeit verlieren denn wir
haben für die heutige episode mal wieder
extrem viel auf ok wir haben hier heute
mal wieder extrem viel auf unserer to do
liste denn ihr seht schon ich habe mir
gerade das kku kopf schild weg gemacht
und er setzte das durch das zweite
hundehütte schild denn wir müssen ja und
das habe ich ja am ende der letzten
episode gesagt noch für balenciaga wegen
baloglu valencia beides mit bl
so heißt ein neuer kind
einfach ich war allerdings auf jeden
fall auch mal wieder in den kommentaren
unterwegs und wollte mir das hier
geschrieben und da bin ich wirklich sehr
sehr dankbar für denn ich habe ja meine
tiere immer nur mit irgendwelchen essen
sachen oder so geführt hat und hier
wurden halt einfach geschrieben luca du
kannst sie eigentlich nur mit einem
trank der heilung so richtig teilen
deswegen nehme ich mir jetzt mal alle
sachen mit die ich dafür benötige werde
auch ganz kurz mal eben rüber laufen auf
unsere was das für ein party typ
[Musik]
ach du deine party weiter ich muss auf
jeden fall ganz kurz zuvor nur
überlaufen und neben mir hier raus eine
melone loch nehmen hier sieht schon ein
ganzes inventars noch gefüllt das muss
ich euch ja teilweise auch noch kurz
sortieren allerdings möchte ich mich
jetzt erstmal wirklich auf den werften
trank der heilung konzentrieren dafür
legen wir jetzt nämlich die melone hier
rein machen außenrum goldnuggets kriegen
dann eine glitzernde melone und machen
jetzt die drei wasserflaschen in dieses
ding reinmachen dort einen elfer war ein
warten kurz sodass wir einen seltsamen
trank bekommen und wenn das sie dann
gleich fertig ist packen wir dann eine
glitzernde melone darauf dass dann
nämlich dass es einen trend der heilung
ist und da ich diesen rang hat auf die
tiere werfen muss muss sein wer fahrrad
angehalten seien deswegen nutzen wir
dann nimmt das schwarzpulver
vorher jedoch noch kurz in klostern
staub so dass das ganze kein trank der
heilung 1 sowie es sieht jetzt gerade
der fall ist sondern ein trank der
heilung 2 wird und das ist nämlich schon
der fall ihr seht schon hier trank der
heilung und durch das schwarzpulver was
ich gerade rein gemacht habe ist setzen
wurf drang der heilung stufe 2 geworden
drei stück habe ich mir davon gemacht
denn ich möchte davon einen auf die
beiden hier werfen also dorthin
was den zweiten wurf trank würde ich
gern auf papa schmeißen der steht
nämlich hier unten
und den dritten wurf trank der heilung
möchte ich gern auf unseren
bürgermeister schmeißen den hab ich ja
auch schon das ein oder andere mal aus
versehen geboxt von daher hat er es
glaube ich nötig dass ich auch unter
anderem mit ihm hier gleich handel dank
kommen allerdings gleicht es tut mir auf
und den kommentare geschrieben und zwar
als kleiner reminder denn ich möchte
wenn auch bis schwarze farbe des von ihm
holen wo es in der bürgermeister dass
das nicht erst seit der herren muss ich
ja genau das ist der bürgermeister von
daher wird auch der bürgermeister ganz
kurz mal eben geheilt und ich habe auch
schon meine smaragde ex am inventar
mitgenommen sodass ich halte die gerade
bereits erwähnt mit dem erfahrenen
händler hier handeln kann ich hoffe dass
mich das jetzt nicht wieder bedrohen
werden wir sind überhaupt die haben und
die bedrohung nicht die ganze gut
der guckt mich an wie so ein idiot gut
auslastet
[Musik]
sie haben sich beruhigt von daher können
wir nun endlich handeln mit ihm hier
also mal schauen er hat auf jeden fall
noch den schwarzen farbstoff davon werde
ich mir auch direkt erst mal ein
bisschen was mitnehmen 15 stück also wir
werden es auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen öfter gebrauchen märz mal 21
stück mit wir bekommen natürlich auch
immer ein bisschen erfahrung 44
erfahrung sehr wohl habe ich
auf jeden fall für die erinnerung dazu
also ein bisschen schwarzen farbstoff
habe ich jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal
geholt und nun meine damen und herren
kommen wir zu dem also dass wir jetzt
erstmal ein paar sachen die ich noch
erledigen mussten
[Musik]
ihr seid viel geld ins wasser nicht aus
wasser jetzt komme ich zum endlich
richtigen ziel für die heutige episode
was ihr auch schon im tam nennen
eingeredet sie weiß ich gar nicht so
genau allerdings geht es um das hier das
schiff reach und sehen das ist ja ein
wenig kaputt da hinten gerade im
horizont da haben wir oft immer
fichtenholz bretter abgebaute bis zu dem
zeitpunkt wo wir dann endlich mal einen
fichtenholz baum also eine fichte ist
gefunden haben und uns mal den
setzlingen mitgenommen haben doch jetzt
habe ich mir gedacht mensch
guck mal hier wenn ich mal ganz kurz die
kleine schweiz sekunde machen ich habe
mir auf jeden fall für die heutige
episode überlegt dass wir das
piratenschiff mal wieder aufbauen werden
weil es halt da hinten die ganze zeit
herum gammelt es ist nicht schön wir
haben es einerseits kaputt abgebaut
andererseits waren und auch die kisten
drin die wir dann mitgenommen haben dort
ihr allerdings noch mal ganz fix eben
kurz meine items und ich werde nun auch
noch mal ganz fix schlafengehen
allerdings wollte ich mir diesen
sonnenuntergang noch mal ganz kurz mit
euch anschauen das ist wirklich
wundervoll mit diesem los flugrost
schild da hinten und dann mit der sonne
wie die hier untergeht und so dann
gucken wir zur anderen seite und wir
sehen hinter dem leuchtturm geht der
mond auf der leuchtturm geht gleich
jeden moment an
darauf hat allerdings nicht weil er
nicht möchte nicht dass hier
irgendwelche zombies monster in
zentralen stadt kommen durch die immer
ganz kurz auf so dass ich mich hier fixe
reinlegen kann lesen und in meinen teil
ich habe mir eine menge sand mitgenommen
und eine menge holz für das
piratenschiff ich habe nämlich in meiner
test wert extra schon geschaut welche
blöcke wieder für benötigen werden und
den ganzen land nämlich einfach mit um
das wasser zu stoppen denn ich habe ja
nur einen schwamm dafür müssen wir auch
noch mal irgendwann wir haben so viele
pläne
dafür müssen wir auch noch mal
irgendwann ins ozean moment reingehen
und vernünftig diesem schwamm raum
entdecken
auf der anderen seite habe ich
allerdings anderen mängeln holzbretter
mitgenommen eigentlich besteht das ding
ja fast nur aus fichtenholz allerdings
ist der boden aus eichenholz ist mir
aufgefallen
von daher vermieter jetzt erstmal ganz
fixieren hier durch unsere denkmäler für
das schaf und für die kuh und sehen dann
dort hinten das piratenschiff und das
für uns heute ein bisschen kümmern
werden wir sind auch generell
noch nie so richtig in diese richtung
gefahren glaube ich also das könnten wir
den jetzt auch noch mal machen ihr dürft
ihr allerdings immer mal so ein bisschen
entscheiden was wir machen sollen von er
schreibt gern und in die kommentare
schon mal was ich in der nächsten folge
machen soll und ich fange immer ganz fix
schon mal an und macht hier vorne den
unterboden bereich keine ahnung wie man
das nennen möchte ein bisschen fertigt
er jetzt hier auf brötchen kaufen dann
schauen wir wie das hier weitermachen
hier würde ich auf jeden fall
fichtenholz bretter hinsetzen an der
seite komme ich jetzt überhaupt noch
hoch ja und dann hier vorne auf jeden
fall die auf jeden fall die treppen das
jetzt schlimm ich mal eben ganz fix
rüber zur anderen seite so dass wir dann
von der seite auch eben mal gucken
konnte hier liegen sie jetzt alles
durchlöchert wir müssen wir uns gleich
auf jeden fall ein bisschen darum
kümmern also das gleiche machen jetzt
auch von der seite setzt sich mal ganz
kurz eben hier im sand block nicht hier
dann so eine treppe und dann darüber
auch wieder hier die fichten holzbretter
genauso wie auf der anderen seite und
das mit dem sand können wir jetzt einmal
komplett hier durchziehen
beziehungsweise geht das ja hier bei
solchen treppen nie so richtig deswegen
muss ich erst mal ganze treppe abbauen
und kommt hier vorne wieder der sand in
ihr vorne setzte ich glaube ich auch
einfach mal treppen hin werde dann hier
noch durch den sand hinsetzen so dass
halt da vorne einfach kein wasser mehr
reinkommt wenn ich hier die ablage baue
ich weiß dass es 100 prozentig deutlich
einfacher wäre wenn ich einfach hier mit
einem schwamm agieren würde allerdings
habe ich halt wie bereits gesagt kein
allerdings habe ich mir überlegt und das
könnt ihr mal in den kommentaren
entscheiden ich möchte mich selbst die
ganze mehr zeit habe ich nicht okay
man muss jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen
was abbauen um dann auf der anderen
seite ist mit dem wasser weiter zu
machen
die sache ist allerdings und das wollte
ich gerade sagen ich hab mir das
überlegt gerade für die nächste episode
und ich glaube das könnte auch ganz gut
klappt ein komitee von allen seiten
wieder sein reinigt idiot
ok das heißt ich muss dass sie auf jeden
fall erstmal kurz zu bauen dann würde
ich das glaube ich auf der anderen seite
machen genauso wie hier also
dementsprechend quasi hallo
man sollte auf jeden fall kein wasser
mehr einkommen beziehen sie muss ich
hier noch ein paar blöcke hinsetzen
genau dann kann ich über einen jetzt
allerdings wieder abbauen
ich habe mir was überlegt für die
nächste episode und zwar hat es auch
etwas mit einem schiff zu tun denn ich
habe mir hier gerade gedacht hey wir
haben hier vorne piratenschiff das ist
ein bisschen old school und wir haben ja
unsere moderne villa die ist ja ein
bisschen mehr new school was würdet ihr
davon halten wenn ich einfach an meine
villa eine jetzt kommt hier schon wieder
wasser rein
ich bin so ein idiot wie soll ich das
denn hier bauen so kann man nicht machen
sie müssen aus den eingang
wenn wir den weg stellen hier noch so
ein rein sonst ok können vielleicht noch
so passt schon
wir machen ja der seite auf jeden fall
sondern kleine treppe nach oben habe ich
nur noch gedacht sagt und sagt dann kann
man hier auf jeden fall vernünftig nach
oben gehen indem wir einfach hinsetzen
hier und dann und wir keine fichten
holztreppen mehr gemerkt ich stehen ein
bisschen neben der spur liegt aber
einfach daran und dafür muss ich mich
auch entschuldigen einfach sehr viel
gerade abgeht in meinem leben ich weiß
nicht ob ich die neue podcast folge
schon angehört habe beziehungsweise ich
glaube dies sogar noch gar nicht so
richtig online geht allerdings heute
nacht online um 0 uhr falls die hören
möchte hört ihr euch gerne ist dann auch
spotify es liegt einfach daran dass habe
ich einen podcast folge auch gesagt und
kann ich euch auch jetzt schon mal sagen
dass ich zurück nach köln ziehen werde
und ich deswegen gerade eine menge zu
tun habe mit architekt ich will nämlich
die kölner wohnung auch so ein bisschen
frisch machen sowie die hamburger
wohnung jetzt einfach jetzt aufgefallen
ich fühle mich in köln bisschen wohler
man youtube video dazu machen was die
neuen gründe sind und auch ein bisschen
ferien dort so vielleicht was leben
vielleicht hilft dem ein oder anderen
was ich gerade übrigens mache ist dass
ich das genauso bauen wir auf der
anderen seite weil ich einfach möchte
dass es von beiden seiten vernünftig
gleich aussieht also einmal so quasi rum
oder waren das hier auch treppen ich
weiß sogar gar nicht das waren auch
treffen von einem
das hier auf der anderen seite noch mal
ganz kurz eben abbauen die sache ist
allerdings dass ich deswegen hat eine
menge um die ohren habe und auch wenig
wenig ich schlafe leider heute nacht
waren es glaube ich zwei oder drei
stunden die ich im bett lag das war sehr
stark
deswegen hab ich auch dementsprechend
augenringe allerdings möchte ich mich
nicht beschweren ich bin dankbar dafür
dass ich das hier alles überhaupt machen
darf und dass er mir die möglichkeit
dazu gibt die sache ist allerdings und
da gehe ich jetzt mal darauf ein was ich
gerade sagen wollte ich hatte mir halt
überlegt eine kleine garten zu bauen für
klein und sind doch so zwei wörter die
man eigentlich zusammen benutzt ich hab
mir allerdings überlegt gerade sondern
kleine yacht zu bauen für meine
strandhaus villa und das wäre eigentlich
ganz neues dann haben wir nämlich hier
unser kleines mittelalter brötchen
piraten mäßig oder unserer strandhaus
villa ganz hinten haben wir doch eine
moderne yacht das finde ich eigentlich
ganz cool von neuer schreibt maloney
kommentare was sie davon halten würde
das die bei euch an den seiten mal ab
wir brauchen ihn glaube ich nicht noch
so ein raum oder so mir geht es auch
eigentlich hierbei nur darum dass wenn
wir von da hinten gucken dass es halt
auf der linken seite ein bisschen besser
aussieht weil wir werde ich nie wieder
drin sein
deswegen hoffe ich hier noch ein
bisschen die löcher aber dann werde ich
auf jeden fall auch nicht wieder zurück
nach hause bewegen hier setzt sich
einfach mal so noch im block dran hier
setze ich noch einen dran wir vorne noch
fichte rein hier fichte zu anderen seite
ist eigentlich relativ egal glaub ich
nenne da werden wäre nie so richtig sein
die laternen setzt jetzt hier oben
einfach wieder drauf sitzen wir hier
eine hin und genauso hier vorne auf die
andere seite und dann noch hier
vielleicht einen draufpackt das ist
jetzt ein bisschen zu nah dran von da
vorne nämlich mal ganz kurz wieder weg
und setzt die hierhin jetzt baue ich
mach gegeben dass hier ab und dann
können wir mal ganz kurz mit dem
brötchen wieder zurück fahren und mal
gucken wie das jetzt aus der entfernung
aussieht es sieht sehr sehr sehr sehr
nice aus also sieht deutlich deutlich
reparierte aus was wir sogar noch machen
können wäre auf der einen seite mal eben
ganz kurz das hier zu bauen und dann
auch noch da wo jetzt gerade die laterne
steht da muss mir noch mal ganz kurzen
kleine leiter hochbau und zack zack
hier noch mal eine ganz kurze treppe
hinsetzen ich glaube dass er dann ein
bisschen besser aus ein bisschen
abgeschnitten da genauso wie hier vorne
sagt hier die treppe hin müssen wir
gucken jetzt laternen setzen also eine
können auf jeden fall hier hinsetzen die
andere setze ich vielleicht nach hier
oben irgendwo auf die ecke in die
hierhin oder so schauen wir mal ob ich
noch mal ganz kurz hier immer unsere
provisorische sand leiter abbauen
und wir gehen ins brötchen und schauen
uns aus der entfernung an was wir heute
geschafft haben
[Musik]
ist jetzt nicht unfassbar geil aber es
sieht auf jeden fall besser aus als
vorher und dafür dass wir das
piratenschiff wirklich überhaupt nie
mehr wieder benutzen werden ist es ja
auch eigentlich relativ egal wieder ding
aussieht aber es sieht jetzt auf jeden
fall schon mal deutlich entspannter aus
und sollte sich weniger durch gelaubt
und gebombt und da die sonne nun
allerdings auch schon wieder leicht
untergeht würde ich die heutige episoden
der stelle jetzt auch schon beenden
meine lieben freunde ist eine andere ist
wahrscheinlich ein quadrat springen wird
ich denke mein studio dass er fast gar
nichts geschafft heute doch wir haben
schon ein bisschen was geschafft das
wären wir hinten mit dem awo haben wir
mit dem lama bar wo haben wir gehandelt
wurden von den lamas bedroht und
bespuckt und haben uns allerdings dann
schlussendlich den schwarzen farbstoff
geholt wir haben unsere tiere geheilt
wir haben das boot wieder aufgebaut wo
ist eigentlich unser starb
us and telephone fest wie die anderen
erst sehe ich dass du willst die sache
ist allerdings dass ja noch weg oder was
dann kommt doch auch hoch ist mir jetzt
auch egal meine lieben freunde ich würde
auf jeden fall an der stelle das heute
braucht gar nicht weggucken kannst mich
gern an guckt man schon mit mir redest
ich habe nie gesagt ja in der nächsten
folge bauen wir die hundehütte okay
stimmt also wir werden es auf jeden fall
so machen dass wenn ihr da bock drauf
habt ich in der nächsten folge eine
yacht bauen werde eine ganz kleine yacht
für da unten für den parkplatz habe ich
mir gedacht das wäre vielleicht ganz
geil um die sonne wieder unter ich sie
zumeist mit dem nummerschild ich die
allerdings einmal ganz fix eben schnell
starten
wir werden in der nächsten folge auf
jeden fall die yacht bauen wenn ihr da
bock drauf hat und mit der hundehütte
könnte mir auch und in die kommentare
schreiben
ich geh jetzt allerdings staffel das
gerne daumen hoch und ein video der
abonniert main kanal und legt auf die
glocke wenn er noch gesagt raus da ich
muss schlafen
[Musik]